Bob Nightingale the USA Today baseball
columnist because the big news was Kyler
Murray and how much he weighed at the
combine but pretty much it was the news
after that Bob which was Bryce Harper
was finalizing a deal to become a
Philadelphia Philly were you surprised
that the Phillies finally securing this
deal with Bryce or and how did you
realize that this was going to do the
team yeah well this was a team you know
back in November I said I said it's only
a place for him to go he's got to be in
Philly I never envisioned going to rag
on for four months after that right he
can't get wait and see whether teams get
involved even as of two days ago called
back with the Nationals or White Sox our
Padres you see they wanted to jump back
in and they were all out
so basically came down to one Phillies
four four and thirty million dollars for
thirteen years or since that's good
Giants you know 310 million over 12
years and I think at the ballpark
everything else a fact he had Giants are
rebuilding you know Phillies where we
wanted to be were you surprised at the
terms oh I mean you get a record you
know a tiny a record number in terms of
the years 13-year contract a full
commitment with no trade clause the no
opt-out just the terms of this deal are
kind of unprecedented what I wasn't
surprised at the at the three third
after I get that I thought that'd be
more like a 10-year contract okay look
you're the Philadelphia Phillies you
love that because your average salary of
that contract is uh no 25.4 right I
don't watch the shorter contract you
know like ten years would have been you
know thirty years so it helps let your
tax implications and all that so I think
Billy's are thrilled you know at one
point I think we're all thinking that
Harper may get four hundred million you
know Mark II just never materialized
yeah we thought about it we there was
rumored four hundred million dollars but
the the three thirty which i think is
obviously a record for in North American
sports for the total value but what does
is what does this do now for a
Philadelphia you mentioned you know
they're there their salary now there
able to now budget for the next 13
seasons that they know 25.4 of it has to
go to Bryce Harper but how have they
positioned themselves outside of Bryce
Harper to get this team to a World
Series yeah they've been a fabulous
winner you know I'm like Andrew
McCutchen coming there
you know trading for Jean Segura you
know I'm getting a closer Jeremy
Robertson and you know pick it up you
know when the two or three best catchers
in baseball JT Realmuto fabulous
fabulous winner and you know now this
gives them you know and I was gonna
chance to get to the World Series you
know somebody you know slight favorite
at least and you know certainly they
have a chance does anybody get to roll
sir is USA Today baseball columnist Bob
Nightingale joining the Rich Eisen show
Kirk Morrison filling in for rich and
just thinking about the Phillies don't
mean the Phillies
and what they've been able to do in
terms of like you mentioned this
offseason and now to secure Bryce Harper
were they really always the favorite
though you don't mean like we talked
about the what they've done over the
last couple of months but were they
always a favorite or is this something
that you know kind of just kind of
materialized more so over the last month
or so no they were always the favorite I
mean they were gonna home from the
beginning you know I said when Harper
turned on the $309 and watch
internationals right there were the Tina
beat and they came in aggressive and
they weren't shy about it you know John
Nolte when I talked to him you know said
I quote we're gonna spend money if even
for stupid about it and yeah and just
kind of they had to raise her prices
that went along particularly when they
had Giants jumped in very late Dodgers
jumped in very late but they're always a
stocking horse in this thing and you
know here's a sign Harper and one day
yesterday after the news broke it sold
at her thousand tickets that's working
about four million dollars to the
Phillies so he you know they a may in a
you know given him ten or fifteen
million dollars just you know what the
ticket sales attendance all said done
just for year one you mentioned the
Giants or Center single Giants are in a
rebuild so when you look at
Dodgers and their kind of last pitch
efforts and we you know heard about the
meeting that the Dodgers had with Bryce
Harper possibly offering forty five
million dollars a year why didn't it
work out do you think for the Dodgers it
was it because of the years or they just
didn't like that number in terms of the
dollars per year yes just in the years
that was it strictly because you know
you give them four year contract you're
still only talking about you know our
sixteen hundred seventy million dollars
and you know you know your time almost
leaving two hundred dollars on the table
obviously they didn't want to do that so
yeah just Rick of the years you know he
could have jumped back in the mark in
three years sure tough to walk away you
know from that kind of money Bob what
what's the the feeling you think now in
Washington you know he spends the first
couple years of his career in Washington
Bryce Harper does and then now he goes
to a National League East rivals in the
Phillies like how are the people in
Washington now you know having to deal
with this no one ever gonna have to see
him you know a lot of times a year now
yeah I think it is all sport I mean
everybody's gonna jump back in they
never did they gave me just a sign and
they had a nice winner who they made a
some pickups obviously got Patrick
Korbin you know paying him I heard forty
million dollars you know obviously you
know they played the second series of
the season in in Washington the Phillies
are out Washington so I'm sure they'll
blue him you know every single bat and
things like that but people Washington
booing would have been nothing like the
Phillies feelings going bonkers if he
had signed with our team but them I
think they would have felt you know a
personal affront to that like our city's
not good enough for you you know you
afraid to be here so I think the
reception Washington be very tame
compared to what it could have been in
Philly you know we've seen the Dodgers
last couple years make it to the World
Series it Cubs as well but we look at
the National League East now what does
this do for the Phillies this year or do
we see this East possibly having a
representative in the World Series this
year outside of just a Bryce Harper
signing for the Phillies
well it's only is the most competitive
division in baseball and he got four
teams you know obviously the Marlins
aren't in there good for those buying
games and one another
I mean [ __ ] are gonna be a powerful
team again you know the Mets have done
you know wonders wit but what they've
done so I think it's gonna be a in the
Braves aren't you know depending
depending Division champions
and their young team so they should be
stronger you know I wouldn't be
surprised to get the closer King Craig
Kimbrel so I think be a fun division and
uh you know and there's not that much
difference between those teams the
Dodgers the Cubs you know Brewers
Cardinals so the National League it
should be a fun leaders year you can
follow him on Twitter at B as in boy
night and Gil Bob Nightingale the USA
Today baseball and colonists and for me
Bob I'm always trying to spin the story
for zai you see that Bryce Harper gets
13 years three hundred and thirty
million dollars and everybody's like
okay who's the next who's the next guy
that can surpass 330 and when you start
to look at some names who were possibly
fallen ly you know with a contract that
can surpass a Bryce Harper whether it's
Mike Trout we were talking to Erin judge
Mookie Betts who do you think could be
the next guy that can surpass what Bryce
Harper got I think just wanted you guys
as either trout or Mookie Betts or both
you know way to earn the career for
judge you get the closer free agency to
get that kind of money no book Benson
trout just two years away same team to
bandwidth both teams want to extend them
so whoever goes first you know it
probably won't happen until next winter
with only one year away from free agency
but one of those guys are not both those
guys she had hit 400 million but when
you look at what the Angels have already
had that big contract for obviously
Albert Pujols but back then it looks
like that contract looks like a steal
right ten years to 54 pools will they be
willing to offer that same type of
contract but obviously a hundred and
fifty to two hundred million dollars
more for a Mike Trout do you see a team
kind of I mean
not the team but do you see the Angels
probably fallen in line doing that again
oh I do I do they want a bad I think my
trout you know people talk about free
agencies very comfortable and I'm not be
stunned if he you know doesn't stay
there yeah I'd like to win there more
often but very comfortable so yeah and
you see them getting him a pay if you're
giving Harper a contract to the age of
39 you know uh you know trout's just a
couple years older so no reason why he
can't get at least a 10-year contract
you know at you know close to 40 million
dollars here Bob Nightingale the USA
Today baseball calmness and and now that
look this signing is now done okay Bryce
Harper is official we had that press
conference he'll walk out he'll put the
jersey on now has baseball season now
officially started now like now that the
big Domino has finally dropped can we
now focus on baseball a spring training
now and start to get some of the other
stories mostly we still got a couple of
guys out there I mean got Craig Kimbrel
knows the best closing game over over
the years just as far as saves and
everything else and also the former a
shy young winner in Dallas Keuchel but
but you're right and now it's a two big
boys off the block
you know when Harper Machado you know
now a lot more attention in the field
rather than every single day you know
what is he going I have an MS he got
seventy five messages a day in question
where's Harper
you know Bob I'm going on my my baseball
spring training tour that I go on every
year in a couple weeks and for me I
remember a couple years ago when I'm
sitting out there
I forget what stadium I was at but I
remember in between innings there was
this little clock in centerfield and I'm
like what is that clock for and it was
the clock in between innings that was
kind of trying to speed up pace and I
think that that rule has helped out
baseball in between innings now there
are some other rules that are out there
and some are being tabled for other
years but what else
on the rules front that the league is
kind of looking at that possibly can
take place maybe this year or something
do they want to look forward to in the
future well they're certainly looking a
hard at the fish clock you know
particularly nobody's on base right
20-second fish clock talking about the
three batter minimum really ever comes
in going pate you know has to face a
minimum three batters before being taken
out also you can only have 13 pitchers
on your roster you can't be expanding a
14 and 15 and you know which increases
bullpen use so things like that
we'll see if it happens this year but
it's coming it's not this year's next
year for sure
and do you see them making those changes
possibly no I mean obviously you want to
speed up the game you want the game to
be more fun and what we want to see more
offense do you think that that will
increase the speed of the game but also
increase the offensive numbers yeah yeah
that's only SP up the game you know a
couple minutes at least you know right
if you add in the you know shorten the
commercial breaks that that has a few
more minutes yeah we could see increase
in our office just that the picture is
getting uncomfortable with that risk
lock-in if they say okay there's only so
many pictures you can use in a game you
know
it forces pitchers to pitch longer maybe
there won't be class defective so yeah
I've seen right could have a
trickle-down effect and get more offense
he is the USA Today baseball columnist
Bob Nightingale appreciate the time Bob
sure my pleasure thank you yes Bob
nightingale follow him on twitter at be
nightingale the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience